are you a dog mom that dresses up your
dogs my little Frankie loves to wear
clothes that's a small a chance couldn't
care less he actually gets really
annoyed olivia's puppy love is the
inspiration for her good works
she's an investor in the dog walking app
wag and this holiday season they're
giving back by delivering supplies to
animal rescues across the country my mom
said that you know when you get a lot
you have to give a lot meanwhile Modern
Family mom and Julie Bowen is teaching
her three boys the same thing we do a
community service every every year
around the holidays they don't they
don't know it I try and sneak it in we
were with Julie spreading some holiday
cheer volunteering for feeding America
one in six kids goes hungry in America
everyday and we are working at the
healthy water station
my boys are chopping and slicing it saw
my strawberries cucumbers mint and
putting them into water bottles and
finally check out Kobe Bryant's big
surprise for these school kids I love
being around kids it's fine father of
three brought a wagon of books to Oxford
Prep Academy in Orange County where
students are learning life lessons
through sports thanks to his new podcast
the puny it's always extremely important
to teach these life lessons to these
young kids at our early age we're doing
in a entertaining way because you know
kids will tune you out right if you'd
like you're preaching all the time this
you like yeah whatever
[Music]